hello my name is Brian Schwarz and I'm  from the University of Texas at Austin  I'm the director of old daddy it's a  father-son story in which the son is  struggling with his new role in life as  his father's full-time care taker I hope  you enjoyed this clip thanks very much  we've got clear skies and clear traffic  on 360 I'm hazel Barnes and this is your  K X om  yeah  so how about you give me 20 bucks off of  this one  but man how you getting the price of the  price  but man you can take the parts from mine  and then resell them and then give me  $20 still do parts you see the price  take it or leave it it's a piece of junk  man  this whole stores junk  dad look I just been to town I got I got  us a TV  Hazel's coming up  dad  hey Dad  hey Jeanie hey Terry you ever see Tom  wandering around have you sure has he  wondered off again maybe if you see it  could you give me a call  you